prime minister  have has he ever considered the  appointment  of his current spouse  to a government post or to any  organization yes in one of the royal  households be honest prime minister yes  or no yes or no  mr speaker i i know why the  uh the party opposite wants to talk  about uh non-existent jobs uh in the in  the media mr speaker because they don't  want to talk about what's going on in  the real world  i'm proud to say i'm proud to say  actually that we now have  620 000  people more in payroll employment than  before the pandemic began which would  never have been possible if we listened  to the right order normal opposite  [Applause]  [Music]